what's going on guys today we're going
through the top 10 moments from my
academia's war arc which is seemingly
concluded in the manga
after over a year's worth of chapters
the 10 moments i've chosen for this
video are my personal favorites
but there are of course many other
things that did happen that are great
but they just didn't make the cut
just before we get into it be sure to
sub to the channel if you haven't
already
and let me know what your top three
moments were from this arc down below
okay so the first moment we're going to
talk about is the initial raid
on the paranormal liberation front
mansion this scene felt like something
straight out of an avengers movie
as you had a ton of pro heroes and
students going all
out against the villains with many
characters putting in their best ever
performance
cementos managed to single-handedly
split the front of the mansion in two
tokoyami took down reed destro at least
you know temporarily
and kaminari saved all the frontline
heroes from his father
okay it wasn't really his father but it
was a guy with a powerful electricity
type quirk
and kamino just absorbed all his attacks
like it was nothing
we also saw the beginning of hawke's
betrayal of twice
which was not only a great fight but it
was actually really emotional seeing
twice his regret
at having trusted hawks overall i'd rate
the beginning of the raid as
certified peak fiction hence why it's in
my top 10 moments
next up the reveal of kurogiri's true
identity was something that occurred at
the beginning of the arc
and this was special for a lot of
reasons as a reader of my academia
vigilantes
finding out that kurogiri was actually
shirokumo was a
crazy plot twist because shirakuma used
to be a student at ua
alongside izawa and present mike
shirakumo's supposed death
is what turned izawa into the character
he is today so to find out that his body
was harvested
and then turned into a villain that
we've known since season 1
yeah that's a pretty big deal aizawa had
a mix of both sadness and disgust upon
finding out this information
but perhaps the best thing about this
reveal was shirakumo
briefly overriding his nomu programming
to give the heroes a clue that would
help them locate shigaraki
this straight up proves that there is
still a little bit of the real shirokumo
left inside
so do any of you guys think he might
return as a hero in the future
with erie being a thing surely it's not
totally impossible
in eighth place we have mirko versus the
hyena nomus
which was a valiant effort from the
rabbit hero to stop shigeraki from
waking up
in truth there were more heroes than
just mirko who took on the nomus
but she was the first one to arrive in
the lab where shigaraki was
and she went up against a gang of high
ends by herself
for what was probably about five minutes
or so seeing this happen from week to
week was very exciting
as we kept wondering whether the heroes
would actually be able to stop shigaraki
in time
at some moments it looked like mirko
would be able to deal with the nomu
but then in other moments it seemed like
she was ready to accept her death
even after she finally made it to the
tank where shiguraki was
it still wasn't enough to stop the
villain president mike obviously was
able to finish off the job
but we all know how things went after
that onto seventh place
this spot goes to izuka midoriya
unlocking his third quark
during the battle against shigaraki this
moment came after shiguraki was about to
touch the ground and kill everyone with
decay
but deku used black whip to grab the
heroes before shooting off into the sky
thanks to his new quirk
which is called float what was really
iconic was that he used black whip to
also pull shigaraki into the air as well
before telling the villain up here is
where i'll beat you
there are very few moments in the series
in which deku has been cooler than this
i mean he's got a new quirk he saved
everyone's life
and he's boldly threatening the person
who just gave the number one hero a good
beat down
float was the perfect counter to
shigaraki's decay and without
it who knows what would have happened
moving on we have the death of twice
which occurred after hawke stabbed him
in the back both literally
and metaphorically whilst talks was
undercover with the league of villains
he and twice became very good friends
almost to the point where you could
forget
that hawk still was on the hero side
however at the start of the war
hawks betrayed twice without any
hesitation so that he couldn't use his
double quirk against the heroes
it was at this moment that we learnt how
cold hawks really is
as he basically made fun of twice for
believing his act
that final scene of twice's clone
returning to toga before melting away
it was nothing short of fantastic and i
don't think harikoshi could have handled
twice's death much better than this
even though twice was the one who ended
up dying it could have very easily been
hawks instead if dabi was more efficient
with his flames
in fifth place we have a moment that was
short and sweet but it was still one of
my favorite things to happen during the
war
ashigaraki was beating down the heroes
it became clear that even with his
quirks erased
he was still virtually near all might
levels of power
this meant that shigaraki with just two
fingers was able to flick a quote-string
bullet towards izawa
as if it was being fired from a weapon
however without any hesitation
the professor whips out his support item
before cutting the bottom half of his
leg clean off
isabella did this so fast that the quote
destroying bullet didn't even have time
to erase his quirk and even shigaraki
had to admit
this was a pretty cool move i personally
know i would never have done the same
thing in that same situation
so kudos to azawa for being that awesome
the fourth best moment in the war arc
was the surprise return of lemilian
which really came out of nowhere
but in a way that's what made it so hype
absolutely
nobody was expecting him to return when
he did clearly not even deku
so for lemelian to appear on the
battlefield it almost felt like a gift
from harukoshi
the way i see it with all the heroes
that have died this arc such as cross
for example
i feel like muriel returning out of
nowhere is kind of meant to compensate a
little bit
for all the heroes that have been lost
after all izawa did say that muriel had
potential to be the next number one hero
so yeah he's clearly a massive asset now
moving on to my personal top three
moments from mikey academia's war arc
the third best moment came in chapter
and it was yeah it was pretty iconic at
this point all for one had taken over
shiguraki's body temporarily
which by itself was already pretty cool
as afo went to attack midoriya with
force quick activation
bakugo's body moves without thinking and
he activates a new condensed form of
explosion
that are faster and stronger than
anything he's done before
these new explosions enabled him to
reach midoriya in time
and push him out of the way but in the
process bakago himself
got skewered by all for one this wasn't
like when afo
harmlessly used force quick activation
on kirigiri
instead these tentacles went straight
through bakugou's body
causing major internal damage when this
chapter came out we had no idea what was
going to happen next
i remember there was speculation in the
comments about whether afo would steal
back and go's quirk
or whether back and go might die and
while neither of those things ended up
happening
it was still super exciting waiting for
the next chapter i cannot imagine bakago
from season 1
sacrificing himself in this way so this
scene really cemented
his development into what all might
would describe as a true hero
the second best moment of the arc was
when shiguraki finally woke up
after the heroes did pretty much
everything they could to stop that from
happening
we got that amazing dream sequence in
which he walks towards afo and inherits
the all for one quirk
followed by shigaraki waking up and
immediately wiping out
thousands of people with just one hand
shiki turned most of the city to dust
killing the number 6 hero crossed as
well as many other innocents in the
process
his new and improved decay quirk had
several upgrades which i spoke about in
a different video
and by the time it was finished only a
stump of ground remained of the hospital
this moment was jaw-dropping like we saw
heroes being
dusted in the streets we saw civilians
who were clearly about to be dusted
it was just it's completely nuts of
course once the destruction was complete
then we got to see shigeraki
show off his new quirks against
endeavour and yeah that was pretty cool
too
with that said before we move on to my
personal favorite moment of the war arc
the honorable mentions for this video
include best genus still being alive
mr compresses past being revealed
kirishima getting the sedative into
giganto marquia's mouth
and gigantomachia destroying many many
cities on his way to shigeraki
okay so the main event is something so
epic
that when this bull is dropped for this
it trended higher than the 2020 us
election
that is not a joke i will link to the
article in the description but yeah
these spoilers dropped in early november
during the middle of the u.s election
and still despite that derby was the
main trending topic which is
honestly one of the funniest things i've
ever seen of course the reason for that
was that in chapter 219
i can't even of course the reason for
that was that in chapter 290
debbie was revealed to be toyo todoroki
who was the long lost son of endeavor
and the brother of shoto most of us
suspected that he was toyo todoroki
but to have it confirmed beyond any
reasonable doubt it was just an amazing
feeling like we've been waiting for so
long it was just really satisfying
seeing the reaction of the todoroki
family not to mention getting more
details on toya's backstory
and witnessing the downfall of endeavour
all at once
yeah that's just ridiculous dabi's hair
being white was also the icing on the
cake
as now there is a clear distinction
between the debbie era of the series
and the toya era of the series going
forward after the reveal of his identity
toyo went on an insane rampage trying to
kill endeavour with prominence burn
then attacking nedjaray before finally
attempting to kill
shoto from the dialogue we could tell
that toya is now a lost cause
because he just has no feelings for
anyone and even natsuo who was his
favorite sibling he didn't even care if
he died
overall the debbie reveal was basically
everything i wanted it to be
but let me know your thoughts on that
down below and of course let me know
your top three moments from the war arc
as well
thanks for watching as always and if you
enjoyed this video then be sure to hit
that like button because it will help
other people find the video
until the next one peace out